c'est intéressant les gages avec genre
mais bien fondre avant le premier pas je
fais quoi le jeu j'analyse des parties
de mon gosse quoi faire pour pourquoi
expliquer aux gens comment les gens ils
font pour bluffer dans le jeu mais après
il peut comprendre je veux expliquer aux
gens comment bien jouer au jeu vu de
nouveau solide et d'une analyse c'est un
jeu de bluff
tu vois pas d'ailleurs c'est bon tu sais
quoi va préparer cette heure on attendre
maintenant comme ça je fini de regarder
cette partie là et on fait l'analyse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
économique se crée un jeu j'utilise les
toilettes
tu utilises les toilettes ah ben oui
j'utilise les toilettes fait mais la
tâche toilettes
voilà des choses non non c'est toi
donc moi j'ai fini avec le ca me reste
pas mal de tâches à faire toi même tu
sais de quoi je parle
ouais mais t'es bizarre mon salut
aujourd'hui vous avez compris on va
analyser et grands joueurs pour voir si
on peut déduire des petites techniques
de blogs chaise de quoi c'est pas toi en
fait je peux pas te laisser raconter
comment gagner à ce jeu va bien c'est
pas possible
qu'est ce qui va faire très bien ce que
je vais faire si papa utiliser le truc
qui a derrière toi plutôt longue
l'idée c'est qu'on regarde des parties
de plein de gens d'antoine daniel de
squeeze de plein de gens en fait sur un
bogey et de voir est ce qu'on peut
interpréter quelque chose est ce qu'on
peut voir sur leur visage sur une
manière de jouer sur leur manière d'être
est ce qu'on aurait pu déceler quelque
chose et ainsi peut-être offrir à tous
les futurs joueurs si je rencontre des
clés un peu comme une partie de golf
mais en poker tu vois là une bonne
méthode
mais avant de rentrer chez les bluffeurs
laissez moi vous présenter monique et
ted qui depuis leur petit hôtel à new
york cherche à monter une grande chaîne
hôtelière est un jeu gratuit sur mobile
qui s'appelle grand hôtel magna je sais
qu'il y en a sûrement parmi vous qui
joue d'ailleurs voir qu'ils ont un
niveau de malades mais pour les autres
sachez que le jeu est très cool dès les
premiers niveaux bon le premier sert
clairement juste à comprendre comment
fonctionne le gameplay est justement le
gameplay est super simple mais
totalement prenant il fallait que je
nettoie une chambre pour digérer les
checking et les check out tout en se
coordonnant pour que tel nettoie les
chambres apporte les p'tits déj et etc
j'ai un café faire je reviens c'est à
peu près ce qui se passe tout le temps
dans le jeu est-ce qu'il faut se
coordonner et aides et il faut pas
oublier puisque tu vois tu fais partir
ted est à oublier de prendre ce qui doit
amener les graphismes sont fun le jeu a
été nominé pour le prix google clé en
france dans la catégorie catégorie choix
des utilisateurs
alors autant le jeu il peut paraître
simple au début autant peut vite se
prendre un gros jus quand il ya beaucoup
de clients qu'il faut préparer les
sandwichs faire les cafés faire les
check-in nettoyer des chambres mais que
tel eric devant la chambre
on a oublié et lui mettre ça dans les
mains parce que on était un petit peu en
speed en plus faut gérer les temps
d'attentes des clients et le ton dans
tes le temps le temps et le temps dont
ted a besoin pour faire ces actions bref
c'est un bon jeu gratuit il vous faut
être au taquet loïc est un thé au taquet
là bref une fois que vous avez le niveau
de loïc vous avez accès des meilleures
chambres du meilleur matériel pour aller
plus vite dans les tâches et surtout
d'autres hôtels com paradise bay se
trouve sur une plage ce style pour
découvrir le jeu vous pouvez le
télécharger via le lien qui est dans la
description s'est vite addictif
d'ailleurs justement parce que c'est
simple et joli et n'oubliez pas que
votre téléchargement soutient cette
chaîne est notre objectif commun vers
l'ultime casse tête je savais très bien
de quoi je parle
le hic zidane nous intéresser c'est
patent non verbal de squeeze ça va être
plutôt sa manière de parler ses
intonations sa manière d'argumenter
puisque quand il joue à mon gosse ils
sont ensemble il ya le discorde
ils sont pas ensemble en train de se
voir donc il n'a pas protégé son stress
physiquement quoi ok c'est bien ça va
nous faire une lecture différente
moi déjà je trouve que cette petite
phrase de départ c'est un peu comme dans
le dans les signaux du mensonge c'est à
dire aller dépêchez vous allez faire vos
missions comme ça en traçant les fume
pour dire je fais partie moi aussi de la
team des gentils c'est un petit peu
comme dans les cimes du mensonge en
général quelqu'un qui insiste beaucoup
sur et je vous jure que c'est vrai je
t'assure je te jure acsta alors que
c'est pas forcément nécessaire il n'y a
pas à convaincre plus que de raison eh
ben c'est jamais un bon signe en fait si
jamais vous connaissez pas à mon gas
bienvenue en 2020 en gros quand ils sont
en train de faire la partie leurs micros
le coupé non quand on entend ce physique
est mort de rire sur le passage que vous
venez de voir où il tue quelqu'un c'est
les autres n'entendent pas ça en fait
après les micros sont réactivées quand
ils sont en discussion un peu comme dans
le jeu du loup garou ou la jarrie des
notes au piano santé mais n'était pas
gelée c'est la seule que j'ai vu des
édiles là il a un bon réflexe ya
quelqu'un qui dit j'ai vu douagui et
jill à l'électricité et du coup il va
pisser qu'il a pu pouvoir dire je
n'étais pas là puisque doit guedj ils
peuvent dire ah bah nous on a vu squeeze
tout seul donc avant même qu'ils aient
le temps de réagir
il a déjà dit ben moi aussi
effectivement je les ai vus je suis
passé vite fait ça c'est plutôt malin
d'avoir fait ça mais moi je l'aurais
déjà interprété comme étant il se
justice
tout de suite en fait pour la défense de
jean pour l'intervention subie that eut
payé il a dit donc pas parce que je ne
sais pas comment il va se préparer à dos
mais moi je te passe de brousse pour la
défense de jill
j'étais avec elle quand on était dans
mort et elle m'a pas buté moi je reste
qu'on peut saboter à distance c'est
drôle parce que là il a une strate
il a vraiment une strate pour essayer de
faire le naïf quoi en gros il défend les
autres y trouve des arguments pour
défendre les autres hélas depuis tout à
l'heure il ay la genre une question et
c'est malin mais en fait en vrai ils
feraient mieux de se mettre en retrait
là pour l'instant à ce moment là parce
qu'ils sont déjà en train de se prendre
la tête sur lui il ferait mieux de pas
apporté d'éclairage sur lui mais je sais
que à ce moment là dans sa manière de
jouer il veut apporter pour plus tard
une construction d' excuses actuelle me
demander attaque collègue jean j'ai pas
vu c'est moi j'ai rien fait j'adore
vraiment auquel défense je vois là bas
l'ajustement il fait quelque chose que
j'aime bien il commence à garder le
silence au mode hockey cuisez vous
faites ce que vous avez à faire
parce qu'en vrai là ils sont huit ans je
donc tonnes n'a pas besoin de prendre le
lead absolument sûr sur la parole mais
c'est plutôt un réflexe de loups garous
entre guillemets donc de personnes qu'un
truc à se reprocher de vouloir rentrer
tout de suite dans les dents les
arguments là c'est bien la strate qui
commencent à adopter en mode geste
discuter j'ai douze mois obama il a fait
un bond vas-y très content qu'elle
choisit le bon vas-y était trop il était
trop ils l'ont entendu j'allais réagir
dessus juste au moment où il a dit luca
il vient de faire un bond asie trop
content oui effectivement
si tu as gardé le silence à un moment
donné il vaut mieux dans ce jeu garder
le silence en fait jusqu'au bout là sont
bons basis était un peu je m'en lave les
mains sauf que c'est je pense qu'il ya
un peu anticipée dans la joie le fait
que ce soit le moment de voter avec le
fait que personne ne l'ait accusé du
coup c'est en train de lui tomber dessus
maintenant c'est intéressant parce que
maintenant il ya un petit soupçon sur
lui léger mais j'ai hâte de voir
est-ce qu'il va paniquer en fait tu lui
il faut que je suis trop
ah oui ok donc là dans sa stratégie
c'est de de tuer les plus malins en fait
de tuer ce qui qu'il suive ou qui le
suspecte et gotha c'est vraiment ça qui
vient de faire il vient de devenir
pourvoir être chez qu'est ce que vous
excuser et du coup squeeze latuelle
chope du coup là c'est squeeze café le
report mais parce qu'il avait vu terre
acide qui allait sur le corps il a tracé
sur le corps pour faire le report avant
lui
je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que ce soit
la bonne sera pas ce que tes racines
avec deux secondes d'avancé donc ça peut
paraître bizarre qui se dit vas-y je
prend le lead et moi je leur ai pas
pouvoir
est-ce que volontairement des fois il
faut report plus tard le corps si tu
penses être sur les traces de
l'imposteur parce que si on le voit à
côté du corps selon le rapport à ça le
claé garde la même stratégie de je suis
un oeil vous avez vu et reposent des
questions un peu au pew ce pour voir et
donner une construction en faite de
théorie c'est intéressant aurait
vraiment j'ai vraiment tout casser en
train de faire la mission la hoya gta
pour le temps que tu vas pas fumer rica
parce qu'en fait vous tu connais pas le
jeu tu vas te dira le mica il va
peut-être
et là il gagne énormément crédibilité
parce que ce qui se passe c'est que son
agacement ne pas pouvoir parler est réel
du coup c'est pas mal d'essayer de koné
à des émotions de sincérité là je suis
je pense qu'il ne fait pas exprès mika
mais du coup ça me saoule ne pas pouvoir
parler et faire avancer le jeu en vrai
et que s'il était dans le camp des
gentils ici l'air vrai en fait tout
autant ne pas pouvoir donner les vraies
infos qui l'a alors que la ses défauts
des infos mais je trouve que ça le fait
énormément gagné en crédibilité
patienter les gars j'ai fait alors à
temps écoute moi donc je vais dans cette
salle là yakoko qu'est dead et je
reviens sur mes pas parce que je
il va y avoir le murder je tombe sur
terrain et donc le gars est parti ce que
voulait dire c'est que le gars est parti
sur la droite de la masse vers le bas il
était tout en main droite il est parti
vers le bas donc elle a croisé au chaud
quand on lui a demandé quels étaient les
tâches qu'il a fait et comme ils sont en
train un peu de découvrir le jeu il n'y
a pas de réponse un stand et il a vu du
coin de l'oeil qu'il restait 15 secondes
et l'a fait wayne écoute moi il a
balancé sa théorie théorique qui peut
être crédible
mais surtout il a gagné du temps avant
le vote en fait là on est on est sur un
problème c'est que si on veut personne
vu qu'il ya des emplois ster on a perdu
pas du tout convaincu que ces mines en
terrasse en terrasse qui lie à paris
portent le corps c'est à dire il est
revenu sur le corps avec moi il à paris
porte et j'attends du ko avant de voir
ce qui va se dire on revient il revient
à sur le fait qu'il arrive parc le corps
en premier alors que terra il va
peut-être dire non à temps c'est toi qui
arrivent et avec a tracé une seconde
après moi qui t'ai précipiter pour
report
j'ai hâte de voir ce que ça donne je
suis là je sais pas si ça gros mois si
j'entends ça en game je me dis c'est
louche en vrai je ne trouve pas que ça
serve la rue j'ai pas vu de corps mettez
à remettre du corps de quoi tu parles
quand vous et c'est à dire que c'est
doivent baisser puisque squeeze au nom
non là je pense qu'il aurait dû enfoncer
terrain un petit peu plus un mode
comment tu peux pas voir le corps si ça
peut pas être ça ton explication de j'ai
pas vu le corps alors que t2 su le corps
est en fait comme qu'on est tout le
temps qu'on ait un poster tout de suite
là il a sa défense de nos lancers pas
moi alors qu'il a un vrai argus sur le
fait qu terre acide était dessus et qui
vient de le confirmer
moi je dois dire son fait je boite ainsi
à l'eau me cattoir
oui mais je demande à me cap pour qui je
vote
daou moi mais moi je vais rester avec
mika comme ça c'est quand même une bonne
strada voir demander pour qui voter et
de l'avoir fait parce qu'après on voit
les votes parce qu'au prochain coup il
pourra quand même se protéger sur le
côté moi je t'ai suivi tout à l'heure et
qui m'a fait voter pour un innocent je
pense que des eaux il l'avait saint-élie
ok là c'était pas mal de commencer par
celle ci parce que justement il
découvrait le jeu maintenant on va
regarder une fois qu'ils sont un peu
plus rodés dans le jeu voir ce qui se
passe pas vu de la gamme bang ok vous
étiez où gravelines ou pas il est là il
a évoqué à demi moore fait qu'elle a
pour l'instant squeeze il se met en
position balle ait commence à avoir
quelques quelques game derrière lui il
se met en position de jeunes dit rien
pour l'instant tant qu'on m'interpelle
pas et on le voit là pour le coup nous
qui voyons sa position corporelle il est
en mode chill et je pense qu'il a raison
et adeline revêtement à 10 to play du
coup de gilles ou mika gotha m'a fait 3
c'est vrai je contiens je les ai vus
hockey en huit mois je les ai vus j'ai
vu c'est inculquer récent les gages
temps avec lui genre même pas 20
secondes avant le avant du portier ok là
c'est un peu tardif pour faire ça c'est
à dire que ils sont calés en mode qui
c'est qui avait vu mikado tout le monde
a un peu répondu trois personnes et
après sur un délai quand on parle de
squeeze là et vendargues m en disait non
mais moi je les ai vus j'ai vu 20
secondes avant qu'ils meurent mais en
vrai c'est un peu tard pour le dire a
été admis ce que si tu étais moi j'étais
à gt électrique all bat avec l'oc 20
secondes avant qu'ils se fassent qu'il
je suis reparti par la gauche qui monte
je suis allé sur la gauche je t'ai vu tu
toi kamel avant de quitter le truc mais
est acquittée avant moi donc
toi je peux être innocenté et voilà
c'est tout ça semble s'embourber un
petit peu il ya beaucoup de e
en fait on sent toute la réflexion de je
vais répondre à quoi là je pense qu'il
va se faire griller sur cette partie
c'est tout ce que je veux non je peux
l'innocenté je peux les nantais jean
paul innocence
on va passer directement à la prochaine
discussion en vrai moi je les annoncerai
qu'on avait vu la même chose c'est qu'en
fait le cas il a dit qu'il fallait la
fessée mission agricole qui après les
martys pourquoi il est revenu faire sa
mission écrit qu en fait je joue la bad
je vois où il ya des missions je me
dirige l'a fait je repars est des fois
je zappe démission les cerveaux des
accusations mais en fait comment l'uqat
a pu l electrical donc là où il utile de
ce que j'ai compris
ouais j'ai fait une mission et je suis
reparti exactement et sauf que là il
m'en reste dedans les tricole que j'ai
pas vu le talonne à bourdonner loc ouais
surtout que tout à l'heure il n'a pas
dit qu'il avait fait des missions c'est
un oui c'est trop a posteriori là il a
mal justifié au premier coup et ça lui
retombe dessus au deuxième
parce que j'ai fait ma mission et je me
suis pas vélo qui fait ça la gare à
l'eau je m'en bats les couilles
moi je ferai mes missions jésuites
l'émission tu récoltes et les 3 mai mais
je sais pas que tu en as 3
systématiquement je connais même pas
cette main mais je n'entends pas compris
je suis pas électrique au jour ma maman
jouait pas inscrits mation givet et une
fois sur deux j'oublie de faire toutes
les missions qui avait un endroit
vraiment savary ça m'arrive sans arrêt
mais ça m'arrive sans arrêt non mais
c'est dingue
il essaie de jouer l'énervement çà çà çà
peut pas prendre l'énervement dans ce
genre de cas je penserai vraiment grillé
en fait peut toujours se dire si j'étais
vraiment dans le camp des gentils
comment je réagirais vraiment est ce que
ta réaction ce serait vraiment de faire
oh la la c'est dingue non
ce serait pas ça ce serait de hurler à
la limite même vital est ici on tue on
prendrait un lead beaucoup plus fort on
joue sa peau c'est pareil je ramène sur
le garrot mais c'est comme quand le loup
garou t'accuse quelqu'un et que la
personne te fais battu moi et tu verras
noms cités villageois t'as pas envie
d'être que t'as pas envie que les
villageois perdre et tu dis surtout pas
tu mots en fait c'est à peu près la même
chose c'est vous m'accusez sur des vous
baser sur des trucs nul diouf sans
prendre en compte que j'ai pas je
m'engage depuis un mois et encore moins
sur cette map
je suis désolé les gars voilà merci je
ne savais pas que tu as forcément les
trois missions point barre y'a pas une
explication raisonnable n'est pas
forcément une tradition on prend la clé
une infinité mission locale mois aucune
mémoire bracelet fait un truc mais là
les gars c'est bon achat obligé de faire
mon martyrs là il est obligé de jeumont
martyrs à il faudrait surtout que là sur
cette game là sur ce moment là il trouve
quelqu'un en fait a accusé en fait faut
juste qu'ils des portes non qu'ils faut
qu'ils trouvent un argument sur
quelqu'un d'autre parce que tu peux pas
jouer le martyre de deux fois d'affilée
voix mais je trouve pas je trouve
personne
je me demandais où est-ce qu'ils étaient
justement on est mort d'accord vous été
témoin quito caméra et je me suis dit
[ __ ] jeunes actifs et deux caméras que
le barça avait deux autres chaude
je pense que derrière il est venu regard
des caméras et ses prix le scénic un
mois je quittais mika qui était mené 4-3
et beaucoup aux caméras mika coutume
pour l'instant d'assez gros si je mens
cependant qu'il débatte
alors qu'est ce comme il a fait martyrs
thaler il devrait débattre maintenant
mais bon ça fait un sort de son silence
il va refaire le martyre c'est sûr voilà
faut vite qu'ils rentrent dans la
discussion là moi je pense qu'il ya déjà
squeeze j'ai vu personne
j'ai vu personne ça va être même le lui
le deal je suis mort il a il n'a pas
pris avec parra c'est toi la discussion
il reste plus que quatre innocent et de
méchant donc à ce stade là du jeu il
devrait être chaud de fou en fait si
t'es pas chaud de fou à ce stade-là du
jeu c'est forcément que tu sais pas quoi
dire et tu sais pas quoi dire parce que
tu as un truc à te reprocher les garages
effet le scanner ensuite je vais aller
faire le truc avec le laser rouge
ensuite je vais vous dire ce qui s'est
passé la lumière s'est éteinte j'ai
voulu aller
triste et sauf que c'est pas du tout
vers là où j'étais allé puisque je suis
allé je suis retourné au scanner en
réalité et ensuite il ya eu le corps
découvert par souscrivent un abonnement
pour moi notez bien ceux ci notez bien
ceci henry est louche depuis le début
soit qu allez vous en la lys et qu'il
est dead il sait que les gens ont voté
contre lui du coup ils en gagnent tous
les soupçons sur henry parce que des
gens peuvent pas s'engager lors de leurs
votes et il dit il peut gagner par
l'intermédiaire de mika mais je pense
que la même lui dans sa manière
d'essayer de tout reporter sur henry ici
c'est que les gens ont voté contre lui
fait plaisir je dois je connais pas
l'état sq je pense qu'on peut s'arrêter
là monsieur loïc non nous ça fait très
longtemps qu'on regarde des partis je
sais pas ce qui va rester au montage
mais je suis pas persuadé que donc on
détermine des choses supplémentaires
comme ça à dire c'est chaud c'est chaud
à toi tu joue aussi en guest un peu
logique en vrai c'est chaud de donner
des vrais conseils parce que comme une
partie de loups garous
en temps normal on a les visages et les
mouvements et où là il n'y a pas grand
chose beaucoup de mémoire sur qui on a
croisé qui était là était fait pas rêver
et surtout il ya à peu près 1000 strates
mais les strates dépendent aussi des
autres joueurs
en général quand même ce qu'on retrouve
c'est que quand les joueurs font partie
des méchants ils ont tendance à ne pas
trop parler si ça parle
donc s'il ya des discussions qui se
lance direct ils ont tendance à garder
le silence
dans la foulée une fois que leur nom est
prononcé une ou deux fois dans la
discussion il arrive à ce moment là avec
soit des questions un peu bizarre soit
des hésitations ou des des mini
accusations qu'on pas de sens qui sont
pas des accusations en dur et quand on
leur demande un peu ce qu'ils etc on a
toujours quand même des trajets un peu
chaude et si je faisais ça un peu
tranquille vis-à-vis des autres
personnes qui coréalise est avéré qu'il
faisait ça je faisais ça faisait ça bref
passons et toi tu faisais potsdam à main
qui sont tout de suite dans la contre
attaque
c'est pour moi le point de repère sur
les parties ce serait ça maintenant que
j'ai vu tout ça les gars c'est hyper
intéressant de voir des partis comme
saddam en gueule si vous voulez me faire
voir d'autres partis
les mettez dans les commentaires mais
témoin le nom des joueurs que vous
voulez que j'aille voir sur tout on
pourrait essayer de se refaire comme ça
une analyse de jeu c'est pas tellement
serbe le coup pas si ça vous plaît dites
le moi dans l'école où après on pourrait
directement mais triplé d'une grosse
partie qu'on ferait ici sur cette chaîne
je vous écoute plutôt dans les
commentaires quand vous parlez en fait
du coup je vous entends pas merci
évidemment d'avoir regardé cette analyse
là n'oubliez pas de la ligue et c'est la
vidéo elle vous a plu n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner en cliquant ici
en activant la cloche ça va ensemble et
les deux sont gratuites mais fait
vraiment des deux je m'appelle toujours
fabien olicard je voudrais remercier
notre partenaire du jour
n'oublions pas de remercier encore une
fois grandhotel manière d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo vous pouvez
télécharger le jeu gratuitement via le
lien dans la description et vous me
direz quand vous aurez pris un jumeau si
et à quel niveau
parce qu'il ya des débats ici de quand
est-ce que c'est simple quand est-ce que
c'est dur et portèrent nominés ne
partait pas comme ça ici je vous mets de
vidéos ça c'est une analyse c'est une
analyse de menteur en fait de menteur
avéré puisqu'ils ont été jugées sûres
mais intéressant et ça c'est une année
de moi même où je m'auto analyse même la
télévision
c'est encore un autre délire à très
bientôt ciao